[Music]
what's up fellow Geeks today we have the
Rog phone 6 Diablo Immortal Edition big
shout out to Asus Rog for sending this
to us this phone was conceived in
collaboration with the Brilliant Minds
at Blizzard Entertainment and when you
know Blizzard's involved you know you're
in it for a good time so before we open
this package let's look at what's in the
outside and on the front you have Scott
looking menacingly and horrifyingly at
you and on the sides of the package we
have all of the class symbols I'm just
really happy I get to see my Necromancer
and Hunter symbols on there because I do
love my skeletons and I do love my
crossbows so with that out of the way
let's open this bad boy up
oh right and inside okay it looks like
we have a map and oh okay so that's
where the charge is okay and there's a
map on the front where we can see things
I think that's what the UV light is for
and we have the Rog and Diablo motor
logos on the back so you know you get an
Rog braided cable it's USBC to USBC and
that's used for the 65 watt charger that
we have here
and let's just clip it in so we can get
our phone up and running once we get it
out of the world Stone but before that
here is a box holding the UV light that
already has given us because there are
secrets on the map that we saw earlier
on and we've been told there are a
couple things all over the place so
we'll check it out so let's just pop a
battery in there and see whether this
works let's see how strong this is and
uh that's all right I mean we can't see
one by one but we have something better
than this let's get this big boy out and
as you can see it covers a much wider
area so if you guys know what the
markings mean on the map and around it
let us know in the comment section down
below let's get into the world Stone
where the RG phone 6 Diablo motor
Edition lies within
let's crack it open guys
it's beautiful it looks exactly like the
wall Stone in the game you got the Rog
and Diablo motor logos on the top as
well in glimmering red now let's take
the top off and Rog you guys always know
how to present your packaging this looks
amazing right off the bat so that's just
unsleeve this and see how it looks like
without the plastic but before that
let's see what other accessories we get
and we have a phone case which is always
a nice touch because we hardly get phone
cases with our phones anymore so thanks
to Asus Rog for that and oh what's this
at the back we got a fancy schmancy di
logo on the back let's just open it oh
so we also get an ejector pin with the
Diablo motor logo on the front and at
the back it says immortality awaits so
let's get into the phone case and rip it
out real quick this is The Shield
blasting Arrow case which is meant for
the phone and it has a beautiful Motif
with even more Diablo Immortal branding
on it as well and of course you need to
let people know that you are a huge
Diablo Moto fan and that you own the
limited edition Rog phone 6 model this
is a stunning piece and honestly I don't
think I need to change my case after
this but let's use the UV light and see
what else is on here and Rog logo hidden
on the side down there the immortal logo
light up as well very nice touch and the
ruins go as well right let's get into
the main star of the show The Rog phone
6 Diablo Immortal Edition nice little
peeling feeling and this is a beautiful
bag sky looks menacing in how you
orientate the phone will reveal the
fires of Hell behind him the RG phone 6
Diablo multi Edition packs a Qualcomm
Snapdragon 8 plus gen 1 processor with a
Qualcomm adrenal 730 GPU 16 gigabytes of
LP ddr5 Ram
and 512 gigabytes of storage display
wise we're looking at a 165hz Samsung
AMOLED screen with a response time of 1
millisecond we also have a three system
rear camera a 15 megapixel main camera a
13 megapixel Ultra wide angle camera and
a 5 megapixel macro camera at the bottom
we have an audio jack and a type c port
and everything else that comes with the
RG phone 6 you can put on an aeroactive
cooler 6 on it as well
so without a further Ado let's start her
up and of course not forgetting our
Shield blessing aerial case
all right nice
oh look it's gone any good player would
know never to lose faith and fold the
ruinous powers of hell but you know what
would fold the Aces and book 17 fold
introducing the Wolves first 17-inch
OLED foldable screen the Asus Zenbook
17fold OLED features six modes of using
the laptop including laptop mode tablet
mode and desktop mode it offers a laptop
experience like no other with its big
and beautiful 17.3 inch foldable OLED
Nano Edge touch screen and transforms
into a portable 12.5 Powerhouse laptop
when folded great for productivity
enthusiasts and now we're back with scar
looking charmingly at us let us uncover
the secrets hidden in this form greeting
us is a live wallpaper of scan his eyes
glowing the fires of hell around him and
he looks so heck and cool it's not a
Diablo phone without a Diablo wallpaper
and Diablo theme icons so let's just get
into I'm going to create real quick and
see if there are any changes or if
there's anything else we can do with
this phone like any other Rog phone 6
you can definitely customize the
settings of your Lighting on the back of
the phone however you like and of course
if you enable X mode on the Rog phone 6
it will by default enable the lights on
the back of the phone this is definitely
a piece you want to show off to everyone
and of course if you're a die-hard
Diablo fan this will be the phone for
you and honestly if you got it flaunt it
and don't forget to bring fario's light
to show up the details the wallpaper
also changes when you enable X mode and
you also get epic music for a default
ringtone it's also really cool that they
have a live wallpaper of all the classes
in Diablo for live wallpaper when you
receive a call what's more is a cool
animation place when you plug a charger
in and you guys just know how to spoil
your fans
also showing you guys we have a refresh
rate of 165 Hertz
alright so we have Diablo booted up
let's see how it settings real quick we
are on 60 frame rates per second be
obviously on high we've got Heights with
everything and let's see what else we
got high high yeah I think we're pretty
much set so let's just get into a game
off the bat the Rog phone 6 feels really
good in hand I expect nothing less after
using the Rog phone 6 Pro performance YX
is doing pretty well so far
let's see how the phone takes on
handling a huge amount of enemies with a
lot of effects and mobs going all around
no firmware drops nothing so far
and I gotta say I have not experienced
any change in temperature my hands are
still cool to the touch and I'm having a
ball of a Time killing all the different
demons in game
so final verdict you know this phone
handles the game extremely well it was
built for this game anyway if you're a
huge Diablo multiplayer or Diablo fan
like I am you will fall in love with
this phone at first sight
if you have any questions about this
phone leave them in the comment section
down below and I'll do my best to get to
them don't forget to follow us on all of
our socials leave a like And subscribe
to us it goes a long way and if you like
the content you're seeing so far check
out these videos right here
[Music]